the site of the moon clips in the Sun
has fascinated generations of onlookers
our ancestors came up with a variety of
explanation some more accurate than
others but over the century it turned
out there was a lot more to learn from
solar eclipses than just how they worked
the spectacle of a total solar eclipse
has led scientists to new discoveries
about the Sun the solar system and the
physics of the universe itself when
humans first started studying the
heavens we didn't know much about what
our solar system really looked like but
solar eclipses did give us some hints
for example that the Sun must be further
away from us than the moon
ancient Greek astronomer Aristarchus
wanted to know how much further and
decided to figure it out with simple
geometry Aristarchus deduced but when
the moon is exactly half lit the
positions of the Sun Moon and Earth must
form a right angle triangle so he
measured the angle between the Sun and
the half moon and used that to calculate
the relative distances to the two
objects since the angle is large the Sun
must be many times further away from us
than the moon is and since they appear
to be the same size in the sky as we can
see during an eclipse the Sun must also
be many times bigger than the moon
Aristarchus was even one of the first to
suggest that the Earth orbits the Sun
and not the other way around though no
one took that idea very seriously fast
forward about 2,000 years and Victorian
scientists were taking solar eclipses
very seriously indeed many intellectuals
of that time were avid eclipse chasers
hoping to learn more about the Sun and
the strange halo of light visible around
it during an eclipse
the founding editor of nature wrote
about the strange halo named the corona
in the first edition of the journal
speculating on what it might be further
study of eclipses proves that the corona
was part of the Sun and not coming from
the moon as some had suggested we now
know that the corona is made from
extremely hot plasma shaped by the sun's
magnetic field it's only visible for the
naked eye
when the moon blocks out the much
brighter light from the Sun itself
around the same time as they were
studying the corona scientists spotted
an unknown line in a spectrum of
sunlight during an eclipse this line
turned out to be a new element helium
now known to be the second most common
element in both the Sun and in the
universe itself by 1919 a lot more was
known about the Sun so in May of that
year Arthur Eddington used a total
eclipse to study something completely
different how gravity bends light he
photographed a cluster of stars visible
near the edge of the eclipsed Sun but
the Stars looked like they were in a
different position than usual this was
because the light from the distant stars
had to pass so close to our Sun that the
sun's mass actually bent to the light an
effect called gravitational lensing it
was the first experimental proof of
Albert Einstein's general theory of
relativity it made Einstein an overnight
celebrity
in the almost 100 years since people
have continued to study the Sun the
solar system and the theory of general
relativity today most of this research
no longer requires waiting for a total
solar eclipse scientific instruments on
earth and in space can study the
universe in amazing detail but some
scientists still travel to the site of
total eclipses and even chase the sun's
shadow in superfast jet
just to see what further secrets these
spectacular events might reveal
[Music]